okay so not that I'm old or anything but
in my lifetime things in America have
gotten a lot more tense when I was
growing up it was pretty common to treat
political affiliation more like sports
fandom I.E I could be a Bears fan and
still be friends with a Packers fan even
if I hated their team but today it feels
more like I'm a Bears fan and dad is a
Packers fan so I will not be coming to
Thanksgiving dinner this year indeed
it's become something of a cliche to say
that America is more politically
polarized than ever before but it feels
true according to USC annenberg's new
polarization index which measures
political polarization on a scale from 1
to 100 America has a whopping 82.5 in
2021 a team of researchers writing in
Politico in 2020 noted that 33 percent
of Democrats and 36 percent of
Republicans feel it would be at least a
little bit Justified and using violence
to achieve their political goals that
was an increase of nine percent for both
parties in 2017. in this climate it's
maybe no wonder that polls indicate that
somewhere between 43 and 50 of Americans
have said Civil War feels imminent in
the next decade or several years
respectively but you're probably
thinking people say crazy things in
surveys all the time give me something
drastic a man might do to get out of
Mariner's girlfriend he gone flirt with
his her mama
but is there actually any Merit to these
fears let's find out in this wisecrack
Edition could America have another civil
war the term Civil War originated in
ancient Rome around the first century
BCE according to a story in David
Armitage he writes the Romans were not
the first to suffer internal conflict
but they were the first to experience it
as civil war Romans were no strangers to
violence and War but violence was never
inflicted on its own citizens by its own
citizens for them it was very important
that war is engaged in by the state be
rationalizable as just in that case How
could a war in which the state was on
both sides of the argument possibly be
considered just it couldn't which is why
ancient Roman commentator Lucan called
Civil Wars wars which would bring no
triumphs arguably the first Civil War
started when a high-ranked Roman
politician with a grudge named sulla
marched his troops through the city
interestingly this seems to have
occurred on impulse Armitage says the
council seems to have had no plans to
March but his loyal soldiers
urged him on what marked this as the
first Civil War is that the soldiers
treated Rome like any outside territory
they were trying to conquer and employed
all the formal signs of War like
trumpets and flags nobody in the Senate
knew how to respond to this Invasion
nothing like this had ever happened
before Sola was Victorious and assumed a
role as dictator of Rome his enemies
sought Vengeance and a second Civil War
ensued just a few years later as
Armitage explains Sola had not intended
anything remotely resembling a military
takeover of the Republic and yet this
act had marked the beginning of a cycle
of civil violence one that would not end
until the creation of the Empire with
the elevation of augustus's emperor in
27 BCE as Armitage notes the phrase
Civil War was spoken sparing if ever at
all because of the harsh memories of
major conflicts the war is precipitated
by sulla's actions would come to define
a huge part of Roman history Rome's
experiences with Civil War as recounted
by many of the Empire's most famous
writers and thinkers would then go on to
influence the Latin West for centuries
stories of Rome's Civil War consumed
European intellectuals and artists alike
according to Armitage inspired some of
the most creative political thinking of
well into the enlightenment he writes
indeed for more than a millennium and a
half Civil War was viewed through Rome
tinted spectacles while it's hard to
definitively say that Rome's history
directly informed early modern European
history this pattern would play out
quite similarly as Europe endured
endless cycles of violence for centuries
European thinkers contextualized these
wars through their understanding of
ancient Rome's past and concluded that
as Armitage puts it civil war was one of
the distinguishing marks of civilization
that is to say you couldn't have a
modern liberal State without the
perennial threat of Civil War this was a
depressing pill to swallow and the
optimism of the Enlightenment era in
Europe which began in the late 17th
century and came to fruition in the 18th
led to some rebranding of Civil War by
intellectuals essentially they took
Civil War and repackaged it as
Revolution as German historian Reinhardt
kosaleck argues theories of Revolution
emerged as a concept in contrast to that
of Civil War Armitage adds that the
nascent category of Revolution was
designed in part to repress the memories
of Civil War and to replace them with
something more constructive more hopeful
and more forward-looking where Civil War
was senseless violence inflicted without
hope for anything better Revolution was
justifiable violence and acted with
hopes of creating a better world the
murkiness of the distinction between
civil war and revolution often plays out
in real time for example when it took
place many viewed the American
Revolution as a British Civil War or the
American Civil War not until a year into
the war to the South Carolina judge call
it the American Revolution and the
language wasn't adopted officially until
1770 9. similarly the American Civil War
was for decades called The War of
rebellion in the north which viewed the
South as rebelling against their shared
state in the South which viewed the
conflict as an international one between
two independent nations it was called
the war between the states not until
1907 was it officially dubbed a Civil
War by Congress thus from the very
Inception of modern Revolution the
distinction between rebellion and Civil
War has been difficult to parse as
Armitage writes it's easy to perform the
conjugation I am a revolutionary you are
a rebel they are engaged in a civil war
today Civil Wars have come to Define
most of the armed conflict in the world
since 1989 there's been an average of 29
Civil Wars going on at any given time
that's because after the fall of the
Soviet Union Civil Wars skyrocketed
reaching their highest numbers in modern
history until 2019 when they peaked
again so it doesn't seem all that
surprised amazing the people are worried
about impending war in America as civil
war scholar Barbara Walter explains if
you are an analyst in a foreign country
looking at events in America the same
way you look at events in Ukraine or the
Ivory Coast or Venezuela you would go
down a checklist assessing each of the
conditions that make Civil War likely
and what you would find is that the
United States a democracy founded more
than two centuries ago has entered very
dangerous territory so why the concern
well Walter is a member of the political
instability task force created by the
U.S government to assess which variables
make Civil War likely the task force
came up with 38 possible variables
ranging from poverty to corruption to
population size and did predictive
modeling to see which factors were most
likely to contribute to Interstate
conflict and to their surprise the best
predictors were not income equality or
poverty it was what they call the policy
score of the nation a policy score ranks
a country on a 21 point scale from
autocracy to democracy with plus 10
being full democracy and -10 being a
full autocracy countries like Norway New
Zealand Denmark and Canada are plus 10.
Saudi Arabia is a minus 10. in the
middle scoring between -5 and plus five
is what's known as a inocracy or a
partial democracy anocracies include
Algeria at a plus two and Egypt at a
minus four importantly anocracies are
the countries most likely to descend
into Civil War as Walter writes all the
things that experts thought should
matter in the outbreak of Civil War
somehow didn't it wasn't the poorest
countries that were at the highest risk
of conflict or the most unequal or the
most ethnically or religiously
heterogeneous or even the most
repressive it was living in a partial
democracy that made citizens more likely
to pick up a gun and begin to fight the
task force found that inocracies are two
times more likely to endure political
ability or Civil War than autocracies
and three times more likely than
democracies we might assume that super
oppressive autocracies are most likely
to Spur the mass anger necessary to
facilitate a civil war but since 1870
the world has experienced several waves
of massive democratization which have
been closely accompanied by waves of
Civil Wars Walter concludes that when a
nation moves from an autocracy to a
democracy this in-between transition
period is when it's at a high risk of
enduring Civil War she writes a primary
reason for revolt is that Democratic
transitions create new winners and
losers because the new government and
anenocracy is often fragile and the rule
of law is still developing the losers
former Elites opposition leaders
citizens who once enjoyed advantages are
not sure the administration will be fair
or that they will be protected this can
create genuine anxieties about the
future this is particularly true if the
country's attempt to transition to
democracy rapidly lie like some of the
ussr's former satellite States as
opposed to gradually like say Mexico but
what Walter is really alarmed by isn't
autocracies turning into democracies
which have constituted a large
percentage of civil wars in recent
memory she notes a more recent
phenomenon an increasing number of
democracies are becoming less and less
Democratic veering towards autocratic on
the quality scale such countries range
from the UK to Hungary to Russia Walter
writes Democratic countries that Veer
into anocracy do so not because their
leaders are untested and weak like those
who are scrambling to organize in the
wake of a dictator but rather because
elected leaders many of whom are quite
popular start to ignore the guard rails
that protect their democracies so what
does all this have to do with America
well long a stable plus 10 democracy it
dropped to a plus five in 2020. the
highest score possible for an anocracy
but an official anocracy nonetheless
though the country surged back to a plus
eight in 2021 the shift was extremely
alarming to Walter she writes a country
standing on this threshold can easily be
pushed toward conflict through a
combination of bad governance and
increasingly undemocratic measures that
further weaken its institutions but
America recovered so we're in the clear
now right well while our anocracy score
did rise back up there's another reason
to be concerned because you know what's
the second highest factor in determining
a country's likelihood of descending
into Civil War factionalism while Walter
notes that early 20th century civil wars
were mostly waged over ideology or class
since the mid 20th century they're often
centered around clashing ethnic or
religious groups fighting for dominance
as Walter explains countries that are
considered factionalized have
identity-based political parties that
are often intransigent and inflexible
boundaries between them are religion
leading to intense competition and even
combat the groups that are competing are
often about the same size in fact it's
this balance of power between the two
groups that creates such Fierce rivalry
fittingly the founding fathers worried
that if the project of the United States
failed it would be because of
factionalism which doesn't sound far off
America's two main parties the Democrats
and the Republicans are sharply divided
by many metrics ethnicity education
level religious affiliation and
geography specifically rural versus
Urban and for the most part these
parties seem to hate each other a study
by Scholars Nathan piccalmo and Lillian
Mason found that 20 percent of
Republicans and 15 percent of Democrats
think the country would be better off if
large percentages of the other parties
straight up died and this might lead us
to assuming that Civil War 2.0 is on the
horizon but Civil War in America today
would not look like the 19th century
Walter predicts that it would take the
form of insurgencies I.E revolts against
the government and preparations have
been made America saw their eyes a
far-right militia groups recruiting
members stockpiling arms and even
traveling abroad to train in the early
1990s but in recent years militia
activity has skyrocketed between 2008
and 2011 the number of militias in
America ballooned from 43 to 334.
importantly insurgencies typically
follow three predictable stages
according to the CIA the first is
pre-insurgency where groups build a
common identity centered around
grievances second comes incipient
conflict where random acts of violence
are committed the final stage is open
Insurgency which involves organized
attacks ranging from guerrilla warfare
to assassinations to bombings of
infrastructure like Bridges or schools
Walter argues that the January 6th
attack on the capital was the first Act
of open Insurgency in the United States
she writes we are a factionalized
anocracy that is quickly approaching the
open Insurgency stage which means we are
closer to Civil War than any of us would
like to believe and as we've seen in the
past this is concerning for a couple of
reasons which we can draw from history
one insurgents will likely view
themselves as revolutionaries and two
the launching of one Civil War can often
precipitate unavoidable cycles of future
Civil Wars and all these tensions are
magnified by social media Walter cites
social media's penchant for prioritizing
provocative content is having material
political effects
um we did a whole video about that so
check it out she notes Myanmar as a
prime example where Facebook promoted
content that fanned the Flames of a
horrific ethnic cleansing despite
persistent warnings from journalists and
human rights organizations that this was
happening Walter argues that social
media platforms pursuit of profit serves
to promote fascism all over the world
dividing Nations turning violent
impulses viral and eventually making
Civil War more likely with the United
States having the third biggest
population of social media users this
certainly seems like cause for concern
but there is another side to all of this
that's equally important as journalist
fintino tool cautions predicting future
Civil Wars can act actually make those
conflicts more likely to occur as it
increases paranoia on both sides so in
some ways predicting a future Civil War
can be a self-fulfilling prophecy what's
more it's important to remember no
democracy that is slid into anocracy has
experienced a full-on civil war yet
Walter is simply calling attention to an
alarming new phenomenon another reason
to be skeptical is that the United
States Army is For Better or Worse way
stronger than it was in the first Civil
War when it was composed of
approximately sixteen thousand members
spread across the country today we have
1.3 million soldiers 900 000 in reserve
and about 450 000 in the National Guard
absent a military coup this makes an
armed Insurrection significantly harder
to carry out furthermore America's
factions are less concentrated
geographically than they were in the
19th century with even the reddest
States containing liberal Urban centers
so it's hard to imagine War breaking out
between regions and short we're not
going to say America is on the brink of
Civil War and not just because that
makes such a thing more likely but none
of this answers the question why all the
interstate tensions well philosophers
have been thinking about Civil War by
various names ever since they started
considering the structure of society
which means at least as far back as
Plato's Republic Plato got the ball
rolling on philosophers being concerned
with the question of how to keep a state
Empire or political community in general
functioning and how to avoid violent
conflict within a polity and planning
his ideal Society he offer tips on
everything from education to child
rearing to should be in charge which was
a philosopher unfortunately he didn't
really account for things like natural
disasters and foreign invasions which
are both factors that eventually led to
the downfall of the Greek polity
eventually this fall got to Thomas Hobbs
who thought that what you really need is
a king who everyone obeys even if he
sucks because even the worst government
is better than the best Civil War
eventually Carl Schmidt a 20th century
political theorist and a literal Nazi
jumped into the chat the state's job for
Schmidt is to protect its citizens while
creating the conditions for any internal
issues to be solved with non-violent
political communication because the
opposite Civil War is the same as the
end of the state itself as scholar Jan
kujowski explains Civil War as Schmidt
puts it equals the dissolution of the
state as this is the end of a
territorially closed organized Unity
that is not available to political alien
entities instead of a closed system
where shared values enable political
exchange we get all out conflict so how
does this happen according to kujowski
the emergence of Civil War might be
related to any sort of situation in
which a political force would emerge
that would gain great popularity that
would be able to guarantee to society
more safety than official state
authorities in such a case the
submission nation of the citizens would
be directed at specifically this force
and not the weak state that would be
unable to provide safety put more simply
when the state seems incapable of
protecting its citizens but another
Force emerges that can or at least
appears to be then a civil war is born
people side with the new force in the
face of what appears to be an
increasingly illegitimate State conflict
ensues this is concerning whether or not
you think your state is doing a great
job of protecting you at the same time
Plato's dream of a long-term peace what
he called stasis is just that a dream
that's not viable in a world where we
can't control natural disasters and
economic turmoil and the idea of a
benevolent Monarch has a history of
going pretty poorly so we're left with
Schmidt's guidelines to the stakes of
and prerequisites for a civil war a
government without legitimacy met by
another force that offers a potentially
better scenario for at least some of the
state's citizens so the best way that
American government can avoid Civil War
is to attempt to gain back a greater
level of legitimacy which is a tricky
feat in such a polarized country and at
the end of the day it would be silly for
us to predict whether Civil War will
happen much less how to avoid it which
is maybe not the most satisfying
conclusion but did you really come to a
YouTube channel to get exact predictions
on the future of American political
stability but what do you all think a
Civil War in America starting to feel
inevitable how can such a conflict be
avoided and why do Civil War seem to be
the new Mainstay of armed conflict in
the world please let us know what you
think in the comments thanks as always
to our patrons please check out our
patreon page if you haven't before it is
the single best way that you can
directly support the channel and the
work that we're doing as always thank
you so much for watching we'll see you
later
[Music]
thank you
[Music]